Take a look around the solar system.
Eight planets orbiting a central star.
The Sun. Among them is Earth.
And its neighbor, Venus.
Earth. Our home is an oasis for life.
And Venus.
That's the stuff of nightmares.
Venus and Earth couldn't be more different.
The earth is this beautiful planet and
there's water everywhere.
It's ice at the poles.
It's water in the ocean.
It's in the atmosphere as water vapor.
But then you look at Venus.
It is the worst place imaginable.
It is so hot on the surface.
Crushing pressures.
It couldn't be any less supportive of life.
To me, the planet Venus is sort of a classic
definition of the word hell.
If you were to transport to Venus and
experience the environment there, you'd
quickly want to return back to Earth.
The conditions on Venus are among the most
inhospitable in the solar system.
It's just a horrible place.
It's so hot and there's no water in the
atmosphere is so thick and it rains sulfuric
acid.
It's going to be a competition between
whether or not you're going to be cooked to
death or crushed to death.
Earth. And Venus may seem like very different
worlds.
But they shouldn't.
They're roughly the same size, same mass and
made from the same stuff.
And they started out as twins.
Early Venus and early Earth were very
similar.
They were twins, probably nearly identical
twins at their earliest stages.
Given that Venus is so Earth like in so many
ways, it's really odd that it is so different
than the Earth. And this makes it one of the
biggest mysteries in the solar system.
Somewhere in their two histories.
The earth. And Venus took two very different
paths.
The result?
Two totally different worlds.
Their paths were so different, you could
hardly believe that one would have been
related to the other.
But now the opposite thing is going to
happen.
We're going to catch up with our twin.
We're going to evolve to be a lot more like
Venus in the future.
In the future, the two planets paths will
converge and they will become twin like once
again. There is going to be hell on earth.
The oceans will vaporize.
The land will melt.
Our hospitable blue planet will vanish,
replaced by a fiery molten world.
We are actually on the earth at a time when
there's water and rain and it was so easy for
life to take hold. But that's going to
change.
And take a look in at Venus and have a look
at our future.
And Earth will surpass the horrors of Venus.
A billion years from now, Earth could be an
unimaginably terrible place.
How will this happen?
The roots of our Homeworld's destruction are
buried deep in the past of our twin planet.
It's very much true that in studying the past
of Venus, we are also studying the distant
future of Earth.
Both planets share a violent birth.
Scarred by brutal planet formation.
Giant cosmic impacts and rampant volcanism.
We're trying to reconstruct things that
happened in the ancient, ancient past.
It's almost like forensic planetary geology.
4.6 billion years ago, hundreds of infant
planets begin to form around the new sun.
Among them, the baby, Venus and Earth.
And as they hurtle around the sun,
collisions are inevitable.
Planet formation is like a demolition derby.
In a derby. The cars are racing around a
track, going around in circles at different
speeds. What's the same thing with planets?
The material is orbiting the sun.
It's going around and they're all going at
different speeds, at different angles,
different trajectories, and sometimes boom.
In this derby planet.
It's planet.
To become one.
Violently.
You have these large bodies that are hitting
each other at really high velocity.
It's really very hot, violent mess.
The amount of energy released in these
impacts is huge.
It completely dwarfs all of the nuclear
weapons on Earth combined.
And yet somehow on these scales you wind up
forming gigantic objects that we call
planets.
Earth and Venus become voracious planet
eaters.
But two spectacular collisions will set the
twins on very different paths.
That was the moment Venus and Earth went
through this divergence to what has now
become these really dramatically different
worlds.
The divergence begins when a mars sized
object hits Earth.
The impact makes our planet spin faster.
The core spins with it, generating a
powerful magnetic field around the planet.
The field fends off the worst of the sun's
radiation.
Around the same time, Venus takes a head on
hit from another infant planet.
This impact explains something very weird
about Venus.
Venus is actually rotating in the wrong
direction.
How could that be?
Well, what if it got hit really hard by some
object that could do it?
An object so huge, Venus stops in its tracks
and begins to spin backwards.
If you think about how much energy and what
size you need to change a planet, spin, that
is an incredibly large hit.
But the backspin is slow.
243 times slower than Earth.
Without a fast spin.
Venus's core can't generate a strong
magnetic field.
It has no protection from the deadly stream
of particles blasted from the sun.
Venus does not have a strong magnetic field,
and so it has suffered the full brunt of this
wind blasted out from the sun.
The tale of two planets now splits radically.
Venus will roast under a violent,
suffocating atmosphere.
Earth will give birth to oceans.
Life and intelligence.
But ultimately, these twins fates are one
and the same.
Earth's future is Venus.
Pure hell.